az amit idáig csináltál azt nézed hogy
hirtelen kezd elslamposodni tehát mindig
mindig mindig új új célokat mindig kell
kitaláljál nem szabad szerintem még
hogyha elérsz tényleg egy
világbajnokságon egy aranyérmet akkor
akkor az legyen a következőó hogy cél
hogy azt azt meg tudod-e újravalósítani
hogy még egyszer
meglegyen nem kell abba haagyni
szerintem mikor elértél egy maximum
csúcsot van vannak magasabbak is pont ez
a stagnálás ezzel igen ez számomra
fontos tanulság volt hogy az ember
amikor céltalanul éli az életét akkor
nem az van hogy egy ilyen neutrális
állapotba éli hogy akkor se nem jó se
nem rossz hanem a céltalanság az
önmagában egy elviselhetetlen szenvedés
az ember életébe és tényleg fontos hogy
hogy célod legyen ezzel tovább